merci Bernard Makro de nous accompagner
pendant cette première demi-heure vous
êtes élu du Cantal mais du groupe Union
centriste et président du Parlement
rural français on va revenir évidemment
dans quelques secondes sur les
annoncières d'Elizabeth band sur la
réalité mais d'abord un mot des élus
local lundi doivent se tenir à Bercy les
assises des finances publiques mais
l'association des maires de France comme
les départements comme les régions ont
décidé que ce serait sans eux manières
de montrer leur colère alors que le
gouvernement leur demande de faire des
économies ils ont raison
alors moi je suis personnellement
favorable à toutes les démarches de
concertation et amener cette
constatation jusqu'au bout aujourd'hui
le constat il est partagé il y a un
endettement public à hauteur de 3
milliards d'euros tout le monde
considère qu'il faut diminuer notre
endettement et réduire notre déficit
pour réduire pour arriver à stabiliser
l'endettement il faut ramener le déficit
en dessous de 3% pour essayer
d'atteindre ses objectifs qui sont
vraiment partagés par tout le monde le
gouvernement mis en place les assises
des finances publiques qui visent à
rassembler tous les acteurs c'est à dire
la Cour des comptes la banque des
territoires le CDE et bien sûr les
associations d'élus les associations ont
fait le choix que vous avez que vous
avez rappelé je pense que tout le monde
doit participer et évidemment à l'effort
de diminution des dépenses publiques
mais évidemment les collectivités
doivent aussi avoir les moyennes de
porter leurs projets et aujourd'hui ce
que propose le gouvernement c'est une
augmentation en volume de 0,5% maximum
pour les collectivités et 0,4 pour
l'État donc l'état fait un effort
supplémentaire évidemment c'est cet
objectif-là doit prendre en compte aussi
les charges nouvelles qui sont imposées
au collectivités voilà donc je pense
moins que elles ont raison
devrait être possible si on
doit y aller lundi prochain
élu en tous les cas moi je suis toujours
partisan d'aller jusqu'au bout de la
concertation
et et et
cette réunion en présence de la première
ministre il me semble que il aurait été
important d'aller jusqu'au bout cette
concertation et d'expliquer les pointes
des accords éventuellement à la première
ministre voilà voilà ce que ce que il
faut participer à l'effort pour des
endettés la France mais les
collectivités elles n'y participent pas
suffisamment pour vous est-ce qu'on peut
encore le rendement je connaissais leur
difficulté les collectivités derrière
les moyennes se cachent des disparités
très fortes il y a des situations
financières qui sont plutôt
satisfaisantes pour les pour un certain
nombre de collectivités et d'autres qui
sont vraiment en difficulté il y a des
collectivités qui sont très fragiles et
l'augmentation l'inflation d'un côté
l'augmentation des matières premières de
l'autre et du coup l'augmentation des
travaux les collectivités les
investissements publics sont
essentiellement portés par les
collectivités font qu'il y a un certain
nombre de collectivités qui ont des
difficultés plus des charges transférées
ou en tout cas les charges nouvelles
comme l'augmentation de points d'indice
donc évidemment il faut tenir compte de
tout ça quand on recherche des solutions
communes à la baisse de notre
endettement on va parler de la ruralité
hier vous étiez dans la Vienne aux côtés
d'Elizabeth borne ou la première
ministre ces mesures pour aider les
français pour aider les élus de ces
communes rurales ces rythmes mesures
pour tenter de répondre aux sentiments
d'abandon de ces territoires on va faire
le point sur ce qu'a dit Elisabeth borne
avec Quentin calmé
[Musique]
bonjour Quentin bonjour Oriane bonjour
Bernard bonjour et
quand on se traitait donc hier dans la
Vienne à la prononcé un discours ou une
ode à la ruralité c'est ça elle était
dans la Brenne donc c'est pas très loin
du Berry non plus pour présenter
effectivement un grand plan en faveur
des campagnes pour rappel on parle tout
de même de 22 millions de Françaises et
de Français qui vivent actuellement dans
des territoires ruraux 88% d'ailleurs un
des communes dans notre pays sont
concernés alors ils avaient demandé en
fait le modèle de qualité de vie je cite
des ruralités elle parlait des ruralité
qui attire de nombreux Français le prend
le plan France ruralité qui vise à
répondre effectivement au sentiment de
relégation dont souffre les habitants de
ces territoires le plan France ruralité
est construit autour de trois grands
axes qu'on a retenus regarder d'abord
soutenir davantage les coûts dans la
construit dans la conduite de leur
projet par exemple avec des
fonctionnaires mobilisés dans les
préfectures et dans les sous préfecture
pour accompagner les maires dans leur
projet autre point augmenter le montant
de la dotation de biodiversité de 40 à
100 millions d'euros vous allez nous en
parler ce que je crois que vous avez
porté ça au Parlement justement
bernadelco depuis pas mal de temps lors
d'examen de projets de finance mais afin
d'augmenter en fait la rémunération des
communes qui préservent leur patrimoine
naturelle et enfin troisième point à
porter des solutions aux problèmes du
quotidien des habitants des campagnes
avec par exemple une trentaine de
mesures sur les transports l'éducation
ou la santé sur ce point d'ailleurs
écoutez la première ministre
nous déploirons sans médico bus avec les
collectivités volontaires apportant des
capacités de diagnostic et de soins
directement dans les campagnes
nous tiendrons également l'engagement
d'une couverture intégrale du territoire
en communauté professionnelle
territoriale de santé d'ici la fin de
l'année
j'ajoute que 4000 maisons de santé
seront déployées partout en France d'ici
2027 en particulier dans les territoires
ruraux
on vous a vu sur les images d'ailleurs
du déplacement de la première ministre
est-ce que ce plan est à la hauteur des
enjeux est-ce que vous le dites c'est
assez ambitieux pour la question alors
je voudrais d'abord vraiment exprimer ma
satisfaction d'accord c'était hier au
côté d'après-midi vous l'avez rappelé
vous savez le combat que je mène depuis
longtemps en faveur de la ruralité pour
une meilleure prise en compte de la
ruralité dans les politiques de l'État
aujourd'hui la première ministre
elle-même annonce que la ruralité sera
au cœur de l'action au gouvernementale
elle a évoqué un nouvel élan pour la
ruralité elle a parlé de d'aménagement
du territoire il y a des décennies qu'on
n'avait pas entendu ce mot dans la
bouche d'un gouvernement et d'un Premier
ministre donc une vraie politique
d'aménagement et territoire donc ma
première action est vraiment d'exprimer
beaucoup de satisfaction
parce que ce projet découvre de nombreux
champs
il est suffisamment ambitieux alors ce
qui est intéressant c'est qu'il couvre
on pourra en reparler de nombreux champs
et s'inscrit dans la durée vous avez
parlé de la question de la dotation
biodiversité on pourra reparler elle a
annoncé la pérennisation des aides RR
qui est un sujet vous le savez qui me
qui me tient à cœur
de revitalisation rurales excusez-moi
qui sont des dispositifs spécifiques
pour les territoires uraux les plus
fragiles qui sont très intéressants elle
a craignait que c'est c'est ces
dispositifs s'éteignent donc elle a
assuré la pérennisation elle a promis la
pérignatation et puis surtout elle a
évoqué ce qui est très important un
ensemble de services à la population
parce que le premier critère
d'attractivité des territoires ruraux
c'est les services qu'on peut offrir à
la population et donc elle a couvert un
champ de service après évidemment il y a
des choses qui restent à proximité
d'inquiétudes et ce qui nourrit le
sentiment d'abandon des habitants de ces
territoires héros c'est le recul des
services publics pourquoi ce plan répond
à ce recul des services publics je
parlerai des services au parce que dans
les services qu'on apporte à la
population il y a les services publics
proprement parler mais il y a aussi
beaucoup de services privés
l'offre de soins de premier recours on
n'est pas sur des services publics la
proprement parler donc sur les services
elle a elle a balayé la question des
mobilités avec des crédits ce qui est
très important on n'a pas transport
quand même la question du logement la
question des commerces la question des
maisons françaises la question de la
santé sur laquelle de mon point de vue
il faudra aller plus loin la question de
la carte scolaire sur laquelle il faudra
évidemment qu'on apporte des
propositions de Love culturelle donc
elle a couvert l'ensemble des services
qui sont importants en milieu rural donc
franchement j'ai confiance dans ce plan
parce que on est bien sur les sujets qui
sont au cœur de la ruralité et qui
s'inscrivent dans une priorité du
gouvernement encore une fois il y a des
sujets sur les qu'il faudra approfondir
et compléter oui allons sur la question
de la biodiversité parce que je le
disais dans ma chronique vous avez
militait lors de l'examen de la loi de
finance pour ce fond pour la
biodiversité
c'est un fond spécial c'est quoi
l'intérêt de cette enveloppe
expliquez-nous la chose est simple
aujourd'hui tout le monde reconnaît que
on ne répondra pas aux enjeux du siècle
sans l'espace rural ça vaut pour la
protection de la biodiversité ça vaut
pour le réchauffement climatique ça vaut
pour la souveraineté alimentaire ça vaut
pour la réindustriation ça vaut pour la
cohésion sociale et donc la ruralité
rend des services à la société tout
entière il faut que ces services là
soient reconnus valoriser rémunéré c'est
le but de cette dotation qui s'appelle
dotation aux communes pour la protection
de la biodiversité et la valorisation
des aminés rurales et comment ça marche
très concrètement alors c'est des
communes qui garderaient leurs être pour
les oiseaux ou qui développent près leur
patrimoine naturel qui serait
récompensés c'est bien cela c'est des
communes qui sont par exemple concernées
par des sites Natura 2000 des communes
qui sont marques membres d'un parc
naturel régional ou d'ailleurs d'un parc
national des communes de même qui
pourraient être concernées par des
espaces naturels sensibles donc des
zones qui sont protégées et du coup
c'est comme une perçoivent une dotation
qui n'est pas
noyé dans la DGF qui est audacieux en
plus de la DGF une récompense dotation
globale de fonctionnement
elle reste mais là c'est une dotation
supplémentaire qui vient à côté j'y
tenais beaucoup et j'avais fixé dans une
résolution du Parlement rurale j'avais
fixé un montant d'une enveloppe minimum
à 100 millions d'euros et donc la
première ministre a accepté cette somme
et annoncer qu'il y aurait au moins 100
millions d'euros pour cette dotation qui
est une augmentation très importante
parce qu'elle est aujourd'hui de 40
millions d'euros donc on passerait de 40
millions d'euros à plus de 100 millions
d'euros cette dotation aux communes dans
les territoires ruraux
puisqu'on parle des questions d'écologie
d'environnement l'un des gros sujets
d'inquiétude des élus c'est le zéro
artificiel des nations nettes elisabeth
bornière a parlé d'une garantie rurale
c'était ce que demandait les sénateurs
mais elle a pas précisé les modalités de
cette garantie rurale est-ce que c'est
un peu quelque chose en trompe l'oeil
vous en attendez plus là-dessus alors
vous savez que ça fait partie des sujets
sur lesquels aussi on s'est battu
nous nous remettons pas en cause
l'objectif de sobriété foncière à
l'échelle nationale simplement nous
voulons éviter que à travers toute une
procédure qui est compliquée et qui part
déjà des grandes régions avec le
stradette je rentre pas dans le détail
des procédures quand on arrive au
dernier échelon à la petite commune
rurale qu'on se trouve avec zéro droit à
construire c'est comme une rurale elles
ont besoin d'accueillir des habitants et
elles ont besoin d'accueillir des
activités et donc ce que l'on demande et
je vais revenir à l'annonce de la
première ministre ce que l'on demande
c'est que aucune commune rurale si
petite soit elle ne puisse disposer de
moins de 1 hectares pour pouvoir
accueillir des familles ou des activités
et hier la première ministre c'est ce
que d'ailleurs ce qu'on a voté au Sénat
et hier la première ministre a annoncé
que il y aurait la garantie rurale sur
donc le droit à construire serait
évidemment mise en place à partir de
2024 parce que les députés en ce moment
ils sont en train de revenir un peu sur
scène 46 rurale quand même très
franchement on s'est battu sur le nectar
moi je maintiendrai cette idée jusqu'au
bout parce que si on commence à sortir
de ce nectar on sait ce qui va se passer
au bout du compte pour les plus petites
communes et je pense je pense que on y
arrivera et je pense au final je le
souhaite mais aussi je le pense que au
final chaque commune disposera d'au
moins un hectare à conduire ça veut pas
dire qu'elle est tenue de l'utiliser
mais en tous les cas ça sera une
garantie rurale du droit à construire
dans les communes rural une question un
peu politique si vous le permettez mais
on sait que ils avaient une borne à 100
jours d'ici au 14 juillet pour voilà
changer la donne reconstruire le lien
avec les Français est-ce que vous pensez
que ce type de plan qu'elle a annoncé
hier c'est typique de mesure qui peuvent
permettre de réconcilier les Français
avec
le gouvernement avec le politique oui je
le pense vraiment si ce plan sur la
ruralité elle est inscrit je pense
aujourd'hui dans le marbre de l'action
gouvernementale quel que soit les les
évolutions ministérielles il y en aura
toute façon un jour ou l'autre je pense
qu'aujourd'hui ce plan pour la ruralité
qui fait encore compléter et approfondir
dans certaines domaines est inscrit dans
le marbre de l'action gouvernementale
quel que soit le gouvernement en place
et donc je pense que c'est de nature à
réconcilier en quelque sorte les ruraux
avec l'action l'action de l'État
en 2019 Édouard Philippe qui avait
présenté un agenda rural c'était 181
mesures justement pour aider ces
territoires ruraux quel bilan vous en
faites aujourd'hui et pourquoi il y
avait besoin d'un nouveau plan alors la
chaîne d'art rural a été une première
étape importante
avec un certain nombre de mesures mais
c'était comment je vais dire ça des
mesures utiles et aimer une
juxtaposition de mesure et ce qu'il
manquait me cette première étape et à
quelle réponse ce nouveau plan en faveur
de la réalité c'est une stratégie
globale qui porte sur tous les champs de
des besoins de l'espace rural ce qui est
fait avec il me semble que là on
s'inscrit bien vraiment dans une
stratégie globale dans un plan cohérent
et qui s'inscrit encore une fois dans la
durée qui j'en suis persuadé
survivra au changement de gouvernement
ou dans les années il y en aura de toute
façon hein dans les mois ou dans les
années à venir voilà je pense qu'on
s'inscrit dans la durée on va continuer
à parler de ces sujets merci Quentin
je reviens dans le club on reparlera du
fond Marianne l'affaire du moment au
Parlement vous suivez tout
particulièrement on voit ça tout à
l'heure on va continuer à parler de ces
questions en réalité et des questions
des déserts médicaux puisque c'est
évidemment un autre sujet d'inquiétude
pour en parler on va voir nos
partenaires de la presse régionale on va
à Chartres retrouver Sébastien Couratin
bonjour Sébastien merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous chef des actualités à l'écho
républicain Sébastien hier matin dans
votre journal dans les cours
républicains vous avez évoqué la loi
pour l'accès aux soins et contre les
déserts médicaux son amendement
controversé pour une régulation de la
liberté d'installation a été rejetée et
Mardine figure pas dans la loi adoptée
cette nuit
oui faut-il le sponsoriser cette liberté
d'installation des médecins ou au
contraire la réguler en fonction de la
densité médicale des territoires en
Eure-et-Loir a été un département
sinistré au plus de 22% des habitants
n'ont pas de médecin traitant c'est une
question qui divise un temps du côté de
la communauté médicale que de la classe
politique c'est ce qui nous a donné
l'idée de faire ce face à face entre les
pour et les contres alors côté pour on
trouve le député MoDem de redouard
Philippe Vigier qui défend un peu le
côté sur mesure de l'abandon une liberté
d'installation totale dans les zones
soudances et au contraire une régulation
dans les secteurs ou la démographie
médicale explose côté professionnel
c'est plutôt à l'inverse à la régulation
est pas vraiment perçue comme une
solution mais plutôt comme un repoussoir
si on régule le peu de gens qui veulent
s'installer nous explique le président
départemental du conseil de l'ordre des
médecins on va les faire fuir encore
plus à entre ceux qui estiment que
l'urgence de la situation impose des
mesures d'exception drastiques et ceux
qui taxent tout Arsenal coercitif de
contreproductif comment vous situez-vous
monsieur le sénateur faut-il réguler la
liberté d'installation des médecins tout
ou également alors il y a une chose qui
est certaine c'est que la situation
actuelle ne peut pas perdurer vous êtes
dans un département vous l'avez rappelé
ou le nombre de médecins généralistes
pour 100000 habitants et l'un des plus
faibles de France donc on a des écarts
de 1 à 2 entre les départements par
rapport au généraliste et pour les
spécialistes j'ai pris le cas par
exemple d'un ophtalmo parce que on a
souvent on a souvent besoin ou
l'occasion d'aller vers un ophtalmo on
est de 1 à 9 de 1 à 9 c'est-à-dire vous
avez des départements vous avez 9 fois
plus d'ophtalmo pour 100000 habitants
que d'autres donc cette situation ne
peut pas perdurer beaucoup de mesures
incitatives ont été mises en place elles
sont apportées des réponses mais pas
suffisamment puisque aujourd'hui la
situation est celle-là et tout le monde
s'accorde à dire qu'elle ne veut pas
rester telle qu'elle est la loi qui est
actuellement à la proposition de loi qui
est elle met en discuter à l'Assemblée
fait une certaine langue d'avancées
notamment sur la permanence de soins
pour inciter les jeunes à aller mais je
pense mais je pense
personnellement que pour un temps donné
on pourrait se dire pour les 10
prochaines années il faut aller un peu
plus loin si on veut assurer l'accès aux
soins pour tout le monde et c'est quand
même ça une comment dire une exigence
nationale il faut aller un peu plus loin
pour les 10 prochaines années et
appliquez au médecin ce qui est appliqué
pour beaucoup d'autres professionnels de
santé d'ailleurs pour les chirurgiens
d'antisent pour les pharmaciens etc donc
beaucoup de professionnels de santé qui
sont des professionnels libéraux sont
aujourd'hui dans un système de
régulation qui permet de d'offrir un
accès aux soins dans ces domaines-là
équitables et donc je pense qu'il faut
aller sur un temps donné encore une fois
on peut le faire sur 10 ans si au bout
de 10 ans les choses sont
revenues à la normale en termes de soins
on pourra regarder mais pour 10 ans je
pense qu'effectivement il faut appliquer
au médecin ce qui est appliqué à
d'autres professionnels de santé en tous
les cas c'est le point de vue que je
défends vous savez moi je viens d'un
département où on est assez proche de
l'Eure-et-Loir alors il faut faire
attention aux moyennes parce qu'il y a
des grosses dispar vous avez des
départements où on sent il apparaîtrait
que l'offre est à peu près convenable
mais vous avez certains secteurs des
départements qui sont bien dotés et
d'autres pas du tout moi j'ai le cas
dans le département du Cantal donc il
faut qu'on réponde à cela c'est
prioritaire c'est le premier critère
d'attractivité des territoires et c'est
surtout et c'est surtout une exigence
nationale de perte tous les Français
d'accéder aux soins et du coup hier
Elisabeth borne allait annoncé sans
médicaments
c'est la bonne réponse alors les 100
médicaux bus apportent une réponse c'est
il s'adresse à des spécialistes mais je
pense que il faut aller des personnes je
pense qu'il faut aller plus loin on va
parler d'un autre sujet Sébastien avec
vous c'est la Une de l'écho-républicains
aujourd'hui c'est Jean Moulin vous
abordez les 80 ans de la mort de Jean
Moulin en évoquant un chapitre méconnu
de son parcours son premier acte de
résistance le 17 juin 1940 au sud de
Chartres
en effet à l'époque Jean Goulin est
préférée Loire ce 17 juin le serviteur
de l'État va devenir en quelque sorte un
serviteur de la liberté à héros
l'occupant exige de lui qu'il signe une
lettre accusant à tort des tirailleurs
sénégalais d'avoir torturé et tuer des
civils Jean Moulin s'y refuse malgré les
coûts malgré l'entreprise de destruction
physique et mentale à laquelle il est
soumis ce 17 juin et les produits dans
un cabanon à Saint-Georges-sur-Eure au
sud de Chartres tenu au secret torturé
dans ce lieu spartiate qui est devenu
aujourd'hui un lieu de mémoire le poids
de l'histoire même 83 ans après est
aussi lourd quand cet après-midi de juin
40 sous une chaleur étouffante dans un
espace exigu j'engoulin est enfermé avec
le cadavre d'une femme démembrée il en
parle d'ailleurs dans son récit
autobiographique premier combat il parle
de cette expérience aux frontières du
soutenable je sais qu'aujourd'hui dit-il
je suis allé jusqu'à la limite de la
résistance alors justement cette
résistance ce terme de résistance en
1940 ne porte pas encore ce nom c'est
peut-être là pourtant dans ce cabanon
que c'est écrit l'un des actes
fondateurs de la lutte contre le nazisme
le jour où ce petit préfet de n'a rien
cédé à ce que le dictait son devoir vous
monsieur le sénateur qui venait un
territoire qui est fortement irrigué à
part la résistance que représente pour
vous le monde Jean Moulin ah ben Jean
Moulin Jean Moulin et dans la tête de
toutes les Français il symbolise la
force de la résistance
la force aussi la capacité de d'un homme
à réussir ce qu'il a réussi puisque au
bout du compte il n'a pas parlé et nous
dans le département du Cantal
le nom de Jean Moulin fait écho à ce
qu'a subi le département du Cantal
pendant cette période noire et dans mon
dans beaucoup de territoires du Cantal
la résistance a été très forte sur le
mont moucher sur la Margerie dans
d'autres secteurs du Cantal et et dans
mon territoire à Murat ou à la suite
d'un acte de résistance ou le capitaine
Gaessler a été abattu devant la mairie
il y a eu des mesures de représailles
très forte qui ont meurtr Ie murale
toutes les familles avec des maisons
incendiées 115 déportés
rassemblés sur la place de muraha
déporté un tiers seulement à peine un
tiers sont revenus donc si vous voulez
cette commune ce territoire ce
département a été meurtri parce qu'il
s'est passé pendant la guerre et
évidemment le nom de Jean Moulin fait
écho à ce vécu qui reste dans la tête
dans le cœur dans l'esprit de toutes les
générations de murailles et du Cantal et
cette absence d'un héros à la Une de
votre journal ce matin merci Sébastien
et à très vite évidemment dans cette
émission on va revenir à la ruralité à
ce qu'elle dit hier Elisabeth Bank parce
que elle a fait ses annonces sur la
réalité mais elle sait aussi adressée
aux maires aux élus ruraux elle est
revenue sur la question des agressions
des lions on le sait elles sont
constantes augmentation on en parle
régulièrement dans cette émission et les
abattement n'a promis que l'État sera à
leur côté qu'elle prendra de nouvelles
mesures on va l'écouter
je sais combien les mers ruraux sont les
bras armés du service public au contact
de nos concitoyens
je sais qu'ils sont le rempart de la
République face aux incivilités face aux
violences
je veux le dire à nouveau fermement
à
cette attaqué la République tout entière
je veux dire aussi à tous les élus que
nous saurons là pour vous accompagner
pour vous protéger nous avons d'ores et
déjà pris des mesures renforcer les
sanctions
l'État et restera à vos côtés et j'aurai
l'occasion d'annoncer des mesures
nouvelles très prochainement quelle
mesure nouvelle attendez-vous vers un
mail alors on va attendre évidemment la
présentation de ces mesures mais en tous
les cas le sujet était extrêmement
important je suis resté maire d'un petit
village pendant 28 ans donc je sais de
quoi se parle et j'ai vu l'évolution
ces mères tous les mers mais les mers
ruraux particulièrement qui n'ont pas de
service qui n'ont pas de police
municipale sont en première ligne et
sont très exposées ils sont en contact
direct avec la population c'est un
engagement d'abord de passion pour leur
commune pour leurs habitants et donc
aujourd'hui dans le comtesse qui est
celui d'aujourd'hui de violences de la
société c'est c'est Meru ont besoin de
se sentir protégé sinon on aura du mal à
trouver des mères d'ailleurs des
candidats pour pour piloter ces communes
donc c'est extrêmement important que
l'État Ethan ne peut pas tout faire mais
que l'État met tous les moyens en œuvre
pour assurer une protection de ces mères
pour comment dire pour sécuriser pour
les sécuriser dans leur action de merde
et que l'État soit réactif je pense que
c'est la volonté c'est la rappeler hier
de la première ministre je pense que
c'est extrêmement important on a eu
beaucoup de démission de mer on a vu ce
qui s'est passé avec des événements qui
ont été notamment il
y a eu de
télécharger de ça au gouvernement est-ce
que il y a notamment le renforcement des
sanctions pénales est-ce que est-ce que
c'est suffisant il faut il faut aller
plus loin c'est-à-dire que encore une
fois je parle du vécu évidemment il y a
les sanctions pénales pour quand il y a
des agressions il fait ça on est
d'accord c'est important il faut le mail
il faut le maintenir il faut le le
renforcer mais il faut aussi que au
quotidien les mers sont protégées
c'est-à-dire que dans chaque préfecture
dans chaque sous-préfecture à travers
les équipes de gendarmerie les mères
puissent très facilement accéder à
quelqu'un qui peut assurer leur sécurité
pour faire part des agressions qu'il
subissent qui sont pas toujours
physiques elles sont d'abord souvent des
fois verbales puis ça se termine par
physique donc il faut que au niveau
local au niveau local les mers puissent
sentir que oui les l'État à travers les
préfectures à travers le sous-préfecture
à travers les forces gendarmerie l'État
est à leur côté dans la proximité pour
pour sécuriser leur action quotidienne
c'est extrêmement important donc il y a
à la fois les quand les faits sont sont
sont arrivés mais il y a aussi la
prévention merci Bernard delcro merci à
vous merci beaucoup notre invité pendant
cette première demi-heure dans 20
minutes dans le club des territoires on
reviendra sur les auditions de la
semaine de la commission d'enquête
sénatoriale sur le fond mariage en
difficulté face au sénateur peut-être se
maintenir au gouvernement ce sera l'un
des débats du club mais d'abord on va
parler du Tour de France Bernard
Delcroix avec Christian Prudhomme merci
à vous